Speaker 1: Welcome back to The David Pakman
Show, I am Ferren cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today, you can find me on social media,
on both Twitter, Facebook and of course Instagram
as well.
At Ferren Balanced.
You can get me on YouTube, YouTube, dotcom
slash the ring of Fire and YouTube dotcom
slash Ferren Balanced.
We've got more to talk about with Afghanistan.
And, you know, not to be outdone from all
of the stupid takes going on out there about
Afghanistan, Marjorie Taylor Greene comes
out with one of the most absurd and quite
possibly disgusting takes on what is happening
in the country.
And without further ado, folks, I am going
to let Marjorie Taylor Green say it in her
own words.
Here she is, an interview from Sunday with
Steve Bannon.
Take it away.
Speaker 2: Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green,
you've heard what President Trump says.
Do you agree with that, given your assessment
assessments?
A pretty big it's a pretty big ask for a president
to resign about something like this.
Do you agree with that?
Speaker 3: Absolutely.
It's a matter of fact, I have my team right
now working on articles of impeachment because
I'm so disgusted with Joe Biden.
You know, I've already filed one set of articles
of impeachment, but but his failure as the
president is, is unspeakable.
Speaker 2: There's reporting that the U.S.
is paying a vast sums of cash to the Taliban
in exchange for allowing the evacuation to
proceed.
Is this true?
Now?
She can't verify that.
And what's going around?
Give us your thoughts on that.
Even the mention of that is pretty stunning.
What are your thoughts on this and what are
you hearing?
Speaker 3: I can't verify that either, so
I won't say if it's true or not unless I had
direct proof of it, but I would not doubt
it.
Look at the way President Biden has the American
military basically running scared out of Afghanistan.
And they were begging the Taliban to give
them time and wait until they could evacuate
from the airport.
And so I wouldn't be surprised at all if they
were paying the Taliban.
After all, they're already paying them with
weapons, vehicles, Black Hawk helicopters,
because the Afghan army army is handing them
over as fast as possible.
Speaker 1: I wouldn't be surprised to learn,
even though, as Bannan mentioned.
Yeah, I mean, there's no evidence of this
Marjah.
Taylor Greene says, yeah, I mean, there's
no evidence of it, but let's pretend there
is and say, oh, I bet it's happening.
That's that's that's how Republican lines
grow.
I hope you realize what we just witnessed
there, folks.
That was the birth of a talking point.
So stupid talking point.
Again, there's no evidence to suggest that
that's what's happening, but why should that
stop them from just making stuff up?
About what's really taking place and by the
way, a little part of that clip in the full
clip, if anybody wants to go and watch it,
it's it's terrible.
But Banan actually mentioned he got those
questions.
From Republican Congresswoman Elise Stefanik
office.
So, yeah, just to let you know, like how staged
all of this crap really is, still phonics
office sent those questions over to him.
I guess in an attempt to get Marjorie Taylor
Green to say something stupid, which, of course,
she never disappoints with that, in case you're
wondering, what's really happening right now
is, yes, the United States has, in fact, worked
out a deal with the Taliban to where they
will not attack the airport in Kabul so that
they can continue to get refugees out of the
country.
I'm sure by now most people have seen some
of the footage of the people desperate to
flee the country, literally climbing on top
of airplanes.
I believe at least half a dozen or more people
have been killed, literally being run over
by airplanes on the runway to the point where
on Monday they actually had to call it off.
They couldn't have any more flights because
the airport was being flooded with people
trying to leave the country.
So the administration came out, had to try
to work out this deal, which they discussed
over and I believe is Doha.
So they worked out this deal and said, listen,
you have to let us get people out of here.
You have to let us get these refugees.
You have to promise to not attack this airport.
Otherwise, they said the general who you help
work out this deal.
If you attack the airport, you're going to
be met with, you know, the swift fury of the
United States military.
So let us get people out.
And we will not attack you.
There was no indication the money changed
hands.
There was no obvious, as she point out, an
exchange of weapons.
And I believe if I may try to make sense of
what Marjorie Taylor Green is saying, the
fact that she's talking about all we're giving
them weapons, no, we're not.
Let's be clear about that as far as I've seen
and feel free to correct me if I'm wrong,
but I don't know that the United States has
made a deal to give the Taliban weapons.
What we have seen is that they have raided.
The Afghan military's weaponry, which, yes,
is full of weapons that the United States
gave them.
So I guess if you want to consider that the
United States giving weapons to these individuals,
then, you know, it's a roundabout way of saying
it.
It's obviously not exactly true.
But technically, sure.
I mean.
Well, I guess I guess you could say that the
United States gave them weapons because we
gave it to these people who then abandoned
it and it was taken over by the Taliban.
So.
Maybe we need to stop giving all these weapons
to people overseas, I don't know, that sounds
like a pretty easy solution.
Heck, we could probably cut down the military
budget, the Pentagon budget every year if
we didn't do that.
So you actually accidentally just made a really
great case, Marjorie Taylor Green, for not
continuing to send United States weapons.
Overseas, I think that's a good plan, and
if that's where you really want to go, Marjorie,
I'm I'm with you 100 percent, I would love
to see the United States no longer sending
our weapons of death all over the planet,
as I'm sure a lot of people on the left would
agree with me on that.
But again, it is just remarkable to see them,
you know, the early stages of a new talking
point, like abidance paying them off.
There's no evidence to suggest it, but we
probably think that it's something that could
likely maybe happen.
You know, it's not impossible.
It's a plausible idea.
So let's just push it and see if the public
buys into that narrative.
That's how they operate.
They don't have to have facts, they don't
have to have evidence.
When you're a Republican talking head or Republican
politician, whatever you can make up
is
what sticks, and that becomes the narrative
that
they run with.